- Peter Piper picked a peck--
- Peck of pickled peppers.
- Picked it? Or packed a pick?
- Picked a peck.
- Pickles make me think
of family, fun, summer.
- I feel like I'm a pickle novice.
- I don't eat pickles very often.
So this is going to be an adventure.
- [Voiceover] Pickled eggs.
Well, I actually thought that
these only existed in cartoons.
- It's kind of like a bouncy ball.
- Oh, hm mm.
- Very sour.
- This is sour.
- Yeah.
- It tastes like a rotten egg.
- I actually kind of love it.
- [Voiceover] Pickled green tomato.
- Oh, it's not an olive, is it?
- Wait, what is this?
- Also smells like a pickle.
- Ahh, I don't like this one.
It just exploded.
- It has the right amount of vinegar in it
so it's not too sour.
It's good.
- I'd rather have 10 more eggs.
- [Voiceover] A dilly bean?
- Yeah, what does that even mean?
- A green bean.
- Cool.
- Cheers.
- No.
- How could something be so rubbery
and so crunchy at the same time?
- It's like pickle's little cousin
or something like that.
Comes around sometimes.
He's kinda cool.
Not as cool as pickle,
but you tolerate him.
Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Pickled herring.
- My first question is
how long has this fish been dead?
- I might be the only black person who
grew up eating pickled
herring in the world.
- Why?
- No.
- Oh yeah, you hate that.
- It's soft. It's also rubbery.
- My favorite thing so far.
- Actually pickled watermelon?
What part of the watermelon is this?
- It's the watermelon part.
Oh, it's the what?
- Yeah.
- The skin of a watermelon?
- Why would you do that to a watermelon?
- That has a slide to it.
- This tastes like
something I've had before.
- It's sweeter than you would think.
(coughing)
- That's so foul.
- Tastes like a hotdog.
(laughing)
- Not bad.
- Not bad at all.
- It was like sweet.
- [Voiceover] Actual pickles!
- That's what I'm talking about.
- Cheers?
- Cheers.
- Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. These are great.
- Classic.
It's a pickle, you don't
need to change anything.
Tastes great.
- We should really just stick to
pickling cucumbers.
(beat boxing)
- ♫ I love pickles
♫ They are delicious
♫ I also like sometimes canicious
♫ I go to your house and
I don't do the dishes ♫
That's all I got.
(laughing)